[Music]
um so I said I I was just this this I
didn't think this was going to come the
prep I was just I watched a lot of like
the world strongman competitions and um
I was I was watching them this is the
guy Thor the guy who plays the mountain
in Game of Thrones and by the way God
damn he got in our boy he leaned the
[__] yeah I said that last night when I
sent this to me I was like he got lean
dude it's nuts but I just out of nowhere
I got a surprise shop uh we're here day
two with the rain fam today we're gonna
do some photo shoots just film a lot of
different stuff for rain you know take
two videos for them I am going to be
that lifting and doing all kinds of
stuff with them plus the amount they're
paying him I'd wear rain too and they
suck but I'd wear it
hitting me we're gonna take you guys
along the way show you guys behind the
scenes of what's Happening
okay here you go
you know who else is sponsored by rain
go to my gym right Jay and then you find
a lot oh yeah but I'll just look like
the rat yeah
papa makes a surprise appearance because
he was at this rain event now Papa
looking puffy says hello Mark Harley
ain't been around no I know right well
he doesn't get the same quality
ingredients
but I'll just look like the rut because
in La I'm shrimp yeah I stay working out
but with doing stand-up comedy I can't
you don't be too big you need to turn
people yeah that's what it is it turns
people off hey you want to be jacked
that's why they're so mean to him yeah
he's too jacked okay you're better I
want to be swollen because salami is so
delicious why does he keep eating a
table of it I can't oh bro is he saying
that you if you're too big you can't
what who told them this who told them
that if you're too in shape like people
like say if I'm too muscular and
gorgeous if people aren't gonna laugh at
my jokes
look man if I stop taking the Xanax I
won't be as funny what
it worked it out but with doing stand-up
comedy I can't you don't need too big be
the church people down people don't
laugh at muscular guys is that it no no
they don't they don't laugh at Mexican
food jokes I like that somebody's
pushing back on this I know
okay I like Thor I'm laughing all the
time your Poison's broken yeah it gets
really tight that's my God how far is
really stoked to get on the the podcast
yeah link him up
asking directly to his face which to me
I know and I don't you love it he just
basically said so your only values
can you get my boy on because you know
that you know that annoys Brenda of
course it used to be a point of Pride
but now it's like every time this music
oh you know Rogan it's like yeah easy
one yeah I'll be good I'd be fine yeah
for sure
it is a gym bigger than this in his
Studio oh wow
you [__] pig no it really is just a
[__] animal you're on camera oh
that's so good that's why his cheeks are
so puffy because he's storing more
[__] Meats for them
all in his cheeks
he just tucked slices into his cheek you
see him yo can I get some more crackers
be
a lot of remember Crackers In My Mouth
left cheeks olives right cheeks Brazil
Brendan sucks so much okay okay let's go
back to lunchable face
face
well
she has like a sauna there here's
everything he's uh he's big into sauna
three cold blondes I've been doing this
for years as well before this guy who's
like English uses like third language
still speaks better than Brad did and
he's close I mean now it's like the cool
thing to do but I have to ask are you
some sort of like a [__] man or
something
because in my country we kill them at
Birth yeah
are you [__] because of birth or I
see your ears were you hit many times in
your head
fighting or playing football we take you
know cold plunges non-stop what do you
do really I'll just vouch these YouTuber
and then I'll do just meat potatoes like
deadlift batch
I was without you know going around oh
yeah going back it doesn't work out
anymore Brandon doesn't work out anymore
Brandon's bad at lying so when he asks
him like what do you work out any person
who actually works out would be like oh
yeah I do this routine even if you're
not even if you're not a pro if you're
somebody that goes to the gym and that's
you'll be like well you go yeah you know
I do back on Monday and I do chest on
Tuesday instead he's like just meat and
potatoes you know deadlifts [__] you
know you know normal stuff
you need to see the video it's [__]
insane
do it we're searching at the first I'll
double that battery
and yeah and it would have broke my
heart if you were like the third
character you unlock in a Final Fantasy
game yeah yeah oh my buddy's like you
watching Game of Thrones are like are
there dragons in it like yeah I'm like
what bro man
in America
I'm a grown man
I'm a grown man who has a man cave as a
set for his show yes
I'm a grown man who wears capri pants
yeah and brightly colored expensive
sneakers
I'm a grown man who still says b
Papa
[__] [__]
I'm like what grown man
in America in that show us
take a show of all time and you're
playing you know big side chair didn't
know because crazy it's been like eight
like years since I was in it like hey
just me asking about Game of Thrones
like somebody asked me about UFC
fighting because I'm finally like eight
years you know what I was doing
yeah but here's the thing that's what
you're known for both of you let me
answer your question that's what both of
you may are known for okay I'm sorry if
I what I want to ask is what happened
with Mark Harley
that's my question Brandon what happened
I was going to calm because I'm like
people would ask me all kinds of hey
Mark you want to come on the show
uh Mark [__] uh Mark's so pissed he
get to meet the mountain I know
do you have those questions
huh that's true right before the steroid
thing came about yeah [__] this because
like I barely watched this show I didn't
read the books uh the show was just so
big it must be bigger than like my boss
so when they were what's big deal which
is a concept yeah I mean I say what's
what's huge and people are like now the
Lannister bloodline when I'm out I like
to show I'm not that big of a joke
everything about him he's like a weird
like like you're [__] on the guy's
biggest show the enemy's shooting on
you're right he's sitting on a guy's
biggest show but everything like him is
is this High School mentality of what's
[__] dragons what am I some kind of
war is suck at Dragon dicks what am I
some kind of queer what's cool to you
Brandon tell me what you sit back and
watch it's so cool
huh getting drunk and talking [__] to
his friends until they quit or [__]
He's forced to fire them I mean he's
such a he's such an idiot you know
what a [__] [__] like this it always
devolves into you don't play sports or
Crush posts and it's always this child
like high school level of like Dutch for
[__] nerds yeah his his idea of what
a human being is and should be is very
Juvenile and gay
no it's like I have about I have enough
foreign
probably ever
and because Brennan always has the big
time everybody he does that because
dude I I killed man I don't know any
character's name like I just you just
said Lannisters just like five seconds
ago yeah just there's a person why walk
there I guess I know that's about that's
all I remember from the show I saw a
seat
she said it shut up shut up shut up shut
up everyone shut up he said it there's a
person why wallpaper I guess I know
that's about that's all I remember from
the show episode
yes he said it he said it oh my God he
said it we Gaslight him enough
I mean I think he probably builts AB CT
no no but he never but he's never
brought it up but he's never said it no
you're right oh my God okay all right so
all right
no hold on hold on
so
there is a pathway
to convincing him that his thing should
be CTE jokes right
it
and we could possibly get a Brendan
Schwab shop special
of just Tracy of just brain injury jokes
you can call it Brendan Schaub huh
he starts going super edgy he's like I
got CTE but I got like I don't have like
to strangle my kid with a Bowflex and
put a Bible next to him CT yeah that's
already better than any joke no I'm
being serious and you was low effort I
get it but that was still better than
any joke that is a lot special or his
first special more than he's ever told
nothing but positive reinforcement from
now on for CTE chokes oh my God be like
yo if Chris benoit's CTE was responsible
then I would have [__] strangled
Ronda Rousey and put a Bible next to her
years ago
he was afraid Mark Carley was Kevin
Sullivan
are you trying to take my girl Beast
[__]
Mountain never been bro no yeah by the
mountain yeah that's my favorite
favorite yeah it makes a Bo make sure to
come out to my brain dead tour it's uh
we played in Anaheim this week I think I
don't know
I understood yeah he was cool with him
in the house
oh okay and now we're done there's no
more branding in this video that's just
what I wanted okay well that was fun
Brendan sucks that was a hit no but
we're not just because we're done with
that video Brendan shows up and eats
[__] salami and talks for a few
minutes and leaves gets paid tons of
money wanna see
Howie Mandel so you won't watch a TV no
no no no hang on so you won't watch a TV
show with Dragons because you're a grown
man yes
but you are dressed like one of those uh
remember when Picasso was drawing clowns
stressed he's dressed like the one of
the Picasso clowns you know what he
looks like you know what the set looks
like like they bought the set torn down
sets from HBO's Carnival
and they were like let's just make it
our set yopi I got it real cheap
nah cause I go to the same gym as Nick
Stahl
that's how I was able to get the hook up
the only John Connor I think
the stadium doesn't have a roof okay hi
Mandel watch how my Dell hates him for
anything right yeah it does oh it does
the new Stadium's number but players
actually don't like playing they've
complained about playing it because they
don't feel like a game why because it's
so new and like the the just the way
like the the lighting and stuff it feels
almost like a like a movie almost they
don't like it yeah
I've talked to people that love it
really yeah on players
maybe the players are lying no I didn't
talk to players I talked to somebody at
bad and Bed Bath and Beyond and they
said they love it can I ask something
Howie is you know but that's how it's
usually nice on every interview that's
what I was gonna say I have never
seen how he Mandel like this angry angry
Jews even this body look at his posture
like he is not he's done he's like yeah
what led up to this though dude I want
to watch this whole wanting to be on Joe
Rogan everybody who wants to be on Joe
Rogan does what the mountain just said
knows that he's friends no what I'm
saying is what led up to the tension
because I don't know I didn't watch the
whole thing I just know that I feel like
somebody would have had to say or do
something to rub him the wrong way I
don't play like Howie Mandel would come
into any situation just automatically
like this in all the years I've like
been you know followed him
um I'll tell you let's see if I can make
it let's see if I could honestly I bet
you just by looking at his body posture
we could find out the exact moment this
is the whole ever this is the whole
episode all right so he's fine here he's
fine here he's fine there yes this is
yeah okay all right he's on the show
okay so so just by Body posture I bet we
can figure it out okay he's fine he's
getting annoyed he's getting annoyed but
he's not annoyed yet it's not over
yeah that's so mean he hung in there
this must be
he's shifting around in the seats a lot
from what I've seen all right okay right
around here right around here and in
fighting huge guys in practice that
would show up that his coach would pay
some monster kickboxer he'd be like if
you can knock him out you get an extra
thousand dollars so he'd talk stop
talking over everybody
I know you're [__] but yeah
it's when he talks over people it's not
like he's interrupting you to give you
something good he's trying to finish
your sentence it's like he's trying to I
hate you I hate you but that's what the
point is you know what's so funny all
right
you know it's so funny when he does this
it's like his it's not like you know
sometimes it'll happen to the best of us
we might interrupt each other because we
have a really Banger line or really good
joke and you're like okay that was worth
interrupting when he interrupts used to
go yeah
it really is bizarre it's
it'd be some stranger who was a
professional fighter walk in who they
were going to spar and he was going to
try to knock his [__] head off and he
wouldn't really wear a headgear the
other guy would
yeah really yeah anyway in her heart
stops or or maybe some musician oh hey
hey sorry sorry
boy that little producer's room looks a
lot emptier now huh yeah why is it yeah
you know why because the creative
director quit too
that I think it was like that Asian dude
that used to work with Mark yeah
oh you think Mark took that guy with him
I don't know I I don't know about that
all I know like I just was looking at
Mark's Instagram earlier and he had
mentioned that he quit too
I guess I wanna I just don't want to see
him get ruined I just I just was trying
to no no no I wanted to figure out it's
almost it's almost over there's not much
here's here
a lot of balls
yeah
as bad as the Rams are everybody at Bed
Bath and Beyond love so far the bald
dick Slinger is a menace Baba can't even
maintain eye contact Brendan's so
intimidated by Howie Mandel that he
responds to him while looking at Brian
Cowan the entire time that is a good
point the entire time he was talking
about what but is it is it because he's
intimidated of everybody like Izzy
always got a one-up people because the
way he talks always about like oh that
sucks for nerds or whatever it's like
it's like an alpha dog like trying to
Alpha Dog everybody when it's like
you're too stupid to Alpha Dog anybody
yeah I think he's uncomfortable and he's
more comfortable looking at Brian he's
looking for Brian for validation on his
stupid [__] and Brian and Brian has to
give it Brian has to give it to him
because he doesn't have a TV deal
anymore yeah
this is real am I the only person that
like Brian callan's voice is just kind
of and I know this is silly of me to say
but it's kind of grating
yeah that's pretty silly for you to say
yeah I'm gonna pull my I'm pulling my
fighter and the kids support